hello ladies and gentlemen went back for
that next episode of the gist and
although this doesn't exactly look like
the Australian office be assured that
you are indeed watching the bright
episode and today we're gonna be talking
about Xbox one games worth buying an
Xbox one to play now from our last
episode of two weeks ago you guys let me
know you weren't that keen on seeing
multi-platform titles included so today
we're gonna be focusing mostly on Xbox
exclusive we would be totally remiss not
to start today off by mentioning our May
game of the month capybaras
super time force super time force is rad
but since this show sort of requires
that I tell you why here's my short to
the game of the month videos long of it
the game falls into the fairly limited
selection of titles that have a truly
unique gameplay mechanic it's not that
the time controlling mechanic hasn't
been done before but unlike games like
prince of persia and braid super time
force does it with crazy complexity and
style needing to constantly rewind time
and employ characters with different
abilities or just multiple clones of
yourself demands a more tactical
approach to what initially appears to be
a mad dash action game and I really do
mean a mad dash because you're fighting
against time on every level now I feel a
little personally ripped off by this one
because as of two weeks ago Dead Rising
3 was an xbox exclusive and then they
announced that it was coming to PC
nonetheless this is a damn good Xbox one
game Dead Rising 3 brings back something
that many modern games have lost and
that's being content with just being
sort of silly and having fun with it
that's not to say the game doesn't still
look cool play well or lack any of the
polish of a blockbuster game but Dead
Rising weapon and vehicle crafting is a
senseless and hilariously irrational as
it is useful and well executed more
moody and serious narrative driven games
like quantum break and Halo a great noir
but sometimes you just need to Don a
onesie and love
listy of zombies with a blam bow which
is across were mixed with fireworks
obviously on top of that the co-op mode
is a great time and a refreshing
addition since engaging to play co-op is
hard to find in more recent games and
now for a game that needs no
introduction or explanation Titan full
well they're technically that was an
introduction and now I'm gonna give you
an explanation
unless you've been dwelling under a
pretty large rock for the last several
months chances I you know about
titanfall being able to fight and
quickly traverse areas as an agile pilot
and fight alongside or take command of
enormous mechs makes for a more
interesting variation of the multiplayer
yes but you probably know that some new
stuff work knowing is that the
expedition DLC pack is out which
introduces three new maps like the
vertically focused swamp the new patch
makes custom weapon loadouts easier to
manage and let you make private matches
with your own settings yeah okay it's on
PC and Xbox 360 too but the bottom line
is a titanfall is great and was a
significant system seller for the Xbox
one so you do well to check it out if
you haven't already and my last
suggestion is forts of 5 which
admittedly is pretty dependent on
whether or not you're keen on driving
games I know there's a mass of driving
games to choose from but if you happen
to have yourself an Xbox one or you're
considering grabbing one this is a good
one to go for there are multiple small
careers that you can choose from so you
aren't limited to a single career path
you still have to complete sections to
progress but it's more choice than other
racing titles the drive atone system may
have a pretty damn stupid name but it's
actually a pretty clever feature that
turn 10 studios have added in models of
driving habits about the players and
recreates I'm using some fairly refined
AI so it's a little different to the
ghost system in other racing games and
it means you can play against people who
are even there and conversely they can
attempt to outrace your avatar while
you're away from your console also
Jeremy Clarkson is in it so if you want
to hear that Top Gear guy talk about
some ports of cars well there's that let
me know in that coming
if you grab any of these Xbox one titles
and whether you think the ps4 selection
beats up the Xbox ones or vice versa
as for the ps4 selection here's what you
guys thought about the games I suggested
from last episode I want you guys Eckerd
the sentiment of unknown or Volvo who
was a bit disappointed in the lack of
triple-a representation in the last
episode saying by the new generation
console to play only indie games and
plenty of you were just downright
unimpressed with the ps4 selection like
project doc you said damn ps4 has no
games for real och I Mills to have an
interesting comment on multi plats
explaining agree on resogun an infamous
disagree on multi-platform
nobody should buy a system for
multi-class especially if they run on
any average PC so far there wasn't much
reason for me to own the ps4 besides
having some games look better than on
ps3 but worse than on PC right now
earning a new console is for its
potential I think four times also
definitely the key there but let me know
what you guys think those are all the
games that I want to tell you about from
the Xbox one and the ps4 but be sure to
let me know whether you think the new
generation of consoles are worth buying
now or if you think gamers should wait
it out a little while longer I'll be
back next week so be sure to join me
then